zugeschaltet ist paul als erstes seid
ihr sicher angekommen
ja wir sind hier angekommen es war
wieder eine nacht ohne schlaf das war
anfangs ford münchen auch noch nie
erlebt habe in dieser militärmaschine
alle immer enger zusammengerückt am ende
konnte ich irgendwo sitzen die hat das
auch nichts ausgemacht aber vor allem
dass sie sehen in die augen dieser
flüchtlinge zu schauen die augen der
kinder und zu wissen dass wir land
verlassen ich weise für immer verlassen
und diese emotionen zu erleben das hat
mich sehr bewegt und hat es andere was
da gestern passiert ist ja fast ins
abseits gestellt dass die amerikaner uns
um verdienen will auf diese maschine
gebracht haben dann haben wir uns auf
die us-militärbasis hier in doha
gebracht und jetzt gerade eben sind wir
hier reingekommen in die stadt frische
zu sagen oder auch nicht so frisch
war eine lange nacht und mit vielen
vielen emotionen verbunden
aber wir sehen hier auch gerade bilder
neben dir laufen und zwar auch ein ganz
ganz emotionales bild eine mutter hält
ihr kind sie ist total erschöpft ihr
kopf wird gehalten von einer hand wir
wissen nicht ist es der vater des kindes
ihr mann das war bei dir in der maschine
wie geht es dir dabei zusehen wie diese
menschen da auch vor erschöpfung dann
zusammenbrechen
natürlich ist denen gab es in der nacht
immer wieder schon als die menschen
eigentlich gegen sehen habe ich ein paar
beobachtet dass umgefallen ist verziehen
weil sie sich nicht lösen wollten von
den grund und boden ja der iren ist und
von dem sie wissen dass findet eben
nicht in den flieger geschafft haben das
ist die große sorge dass bild meint es
hat mein kollege ja was die tafel so
fotograf und kameramann gemacht ein
bisschen chronisches bild man sieht dort
die hand wir gehen davon aus dass es
ihre mutter gewesen ist und die
großmutter des babys die diese frau buch
ruhig wir haben es von seiten beobachten
können viele in diesen flieger hatten
tatsächlich auf flugangst und das erste
mal geflogen und dann in so einer
maschine aber das schwerste für viele
junge menschen mit seh nicht so
abgesprochen aber war dass sie angst
haben um ihre freunde und verwandten um
die menschen sie schmeckt über diese
mauer geschafft haben nicht geschafft
haben über das geht noch in den
kommenden tagen nicht schaffen werden
und die zurückbleiben und wird hilfe
jemand auch in dem alter
wieder ihr baby in der hand hält
wirklich ein bild das man so oft einer
dieser maschinen noch nie gesehen hat
aber viele ähnliche geschichten drum
herum die mir erzählt haben dass sie
einfach sorge haben dass alle ihre
freunde von den taliban umgebracht
werden paul in einer solchen situation
ist es extrem wichtig dass reporter vor
ort sind und berichten können weil die
lage im so unübersichtlich ist
informationen aus erster hand zu
bekommen was war die begründung der
amerikanischen streitkräfte dich nicht
aus dem flughafen heraus nach kabul
hineinzulassen
ja du machst mir für einen hin und her
morgen als wir ankamen hieß es noch okay
wenn ihr euch selbst eine f wort
organisieren können dann die hieraus auf
dem flughafen dann mittags ist es sofort
vor dem ist weg das habe der general
entschieden dann ist es wieder das
gebiet verhandlungen auf höchster ebene
offenbar mit dem us außenministerium mit
dem kurs außenminister ob man doch etwas
hinbekommt und dann die entscheidung
nein ihr müsst ihn die begründung
offizielle begründung des militärs dort
war das sicherheitsrisiko uns die
tatsache dass die us armee den flughafen
kontrolliert auf meine frage hin zu
sagen ja natürlich wir verlassen diese
phase sie wollen die stadt was ohnehin
unser vorhaben was nach kabul wo wir an
den vergangenen monaten immer wieder
lange berichtet haben und auch viele
viele menschen kennen und da hat man uns
dann gesagt nein dieses
sicherheitsrisiko für einmal nicht
eingehen wenn uns etwas passieren würde
dann seien es dass du hast ja schuld
weil sie uns auf dem flughafen gelassen
haben eine sehr abenteuerliche
begründung weil für uns journalisten für
journalisten die schon viel aus kriegs-
und krisenregionen berichtet haben gilt
jeder reporter muss zusammen mit seinem
medium abschätzen welche frieden
vorangehen will uns zu richten aber wenn
er dann oder sie das risiko so
einschätzt dass man rein kann dass man
bild weil die geschichte so wichtig ist
weil die schicksale so wichtig sind und
das sind ja in afghanistan denn das was
dort passiert dieses faktische spielen
der taliban zu sagen ja das wird so nahm
uns schon ein bisschen geändert wird
alles nicht so schlimm da gibt es ja
bereits ganz viele berichte von solcher
gegen frauen von wohltaten gegen
homosexuelle da gibt es diese erster
bericht und da muss hingeschaut werden
also für uns war klar wir wollen da rein
und wir werden auch in zukunft weiter
versuchen da rein zu kommen was
natürlich nicht leicht ist momentan weil
die usa den flughafen ist sichtbar genau
das wollte ich gerade fragen paul wie
siehst du denn die chancen noch mal
zurück zu fliegen nach afghanistan und
vielleicht kannst du uns auch noch mal
ein paar eindrücke von gestern schildern
als du ein kabul am flughafen fast ich
bin in jedem fall nach afghanistan wie
weit es geht weil es möglich ist
natürlich und das gehört dazu auch nach
einer risikoabwägung wenn wir für vortag
nicht einfach irgendwo rein ohne einen
plan zu haben sondern wir wissen schon
ganz genau was sie wollen und dann gibt
es natürlich ein risiko aber das ist
dann ein abgehobenes diesen vor also
dass auf jeden fall was ich da gestern
erlebt habe muss ich sagen das ist mir
unter die haut gegangen weil auf der
einen seite zu sehen diese freude dass
es leute geschafft haben daran
gleichzeitige trauer darüber dass es
andere nicht geschafft haben die auf der
anderen seite sind ja das ist nur zwei
welten an diesem flughafen auf der einen
seite dieses jahr organisierte fällt mit
der bundeswehr den amerikanern wo dann
alle slots aber vor dem tor das die
hölle los und das immer noch die hölle
los und jetzt ist es noch viel
schwieriger geworden weil die usa eine
besondere terror stufe eine warnung
ausgegeben haben und alle amerikaner
gewann haben heute nichts von diesen
spots zu gehen man befürchtet einen
einschlag von icis das ist das besondere
ja auch das eis ist gegen die taliban
kämpft man würde ja denken die
vereinigen sich aber nein da gibt es
auch auf bestimmte gruppen in
afghanistan was die sache so kompliziert
was also keine guten nachrichten für
diejenigen die es immer noch versuchen
dort hinzukommen darunter auch viele die
nach deutschland vor paul was passiert
eigentlich mit den flüchtlingen mit
denen mit denen du zusammen geflogen ist
nach doha und viele andere sind ja auch
vorher schon dorthin ausgeflogen worden
wie geht es für die da in doha in katar
eigentlich weiter
die kommen jetzt in quarantäne und
werden dann in die usa
weitergeben sie sagen uns dass das ganze
so zu sagen als wissen nicht genau in
welchen start gehen sie wissen nicht
genau in welchen ort zu gehen das ist
ein lebens ja ein völlig neues leben und
so mal wenn man deutlich sagen kinder
die es in der maschine sind dann fragt
man sich wie es gibt das in 20 jahren
sein wenn sie sich noch erinnern können
ob sie wie sie ihre heimat verlassen
haben werden sie irgendwann zurückkehren
können wird es ein land wieder auch ohne
die taliban geben können dafür zu
bedanken die an da durch den kopf gehen
eigentlich eine 20-jährige
rekapitulation werden was die bundeswehr
was die us-armee ist
paul der letzte frage für den moment
dort in doha wo du jetzt bist hat ja der
deutsche verhandlungsführer petzold mit
den taliban gesprochen und angeblich
soll es so sein dass die taliban
zugesichert haben dass auch über den 31
august hinaus dann mit zivilmaschinen
afghanen die die nötigen papiere haben
ausgeflogen werden können erste frage
glaubst du das zweite frage ist das
überhaupt möglich denn der zivile teil
des flughafens ist ja in großen teilen
zerstört inklusive rather anlage
zivilen teil will man natürlich so
schnell wie möglich wieder aufbauen aber
da ist man auch darauf angewiesen dass
überhaupt internationales liga kommen
zum beispiel aus der türkei oder aus
dubai dafür muss es schon eine gewisse
ruhe im land wieder gegen was schwer
vorstellbar ist was markus fröschl
angeht diesen sondervermittler sozusagen
der swiss nicht optimistisch dass das
funktionieren kann warum auch immer ich
war bei den gesprächen nicht dabei habe
mit taliban gesprochen wie eine ähnliche
dinge erzählt haben wir wollen tolle
beziehungen zum westen haben wir wollen
die partie aber bitte nicht euch nicht
eins wenn wir frauen hinrichten wenn die
homosexuellen richten also das wird dann
die große frage sein was ist mit unserem
geld wenn die taliban
massenhinrichtungen vornehmen wenn die
kreuzfahrten vornehmen und man kann ja
schon drehenden teilen des landes dass
das ganze schon beginnt
[Musik]